voilà la bête 1900 alors on a à dire
quelque chose
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je vous emmène
aujourd'hui à l'élysée hommes on est
bien évidemment paris fait un temps
magnifique ciel bleu qu'ils ont qui
chante il fait chaud il fait beau pour
vous pas d'un nouveau smartphone de chez
omis c'est le mil neuf aces eux il ya
déjà eu 2009 qui était présenté il ya
quelques temps quand on était à
barcelone
si vous en souvenez on en a déjà parlé
ensemble lie à lui et ce alors est ce
c'est pas un modèle lights un modèle un
peu moins cher est ce special edition on
sait pas réellement que veut dire est ce
vous fasse un choix très intéressant
j'ai emmené avec moi et je compte sur
vous pour me dire ce que vous en pensez
dès maintenant en commentaire femme kate
vernon est-ce que tout cas vous
l'attendez parce que vous l'avez pas
encore vue bien évidemment tout de suite
par contre pouvait déjà lâché un gros
pouce et ça c'est plutôt bien
[Musique]
pas
un peu trop fort
tous
voilà donc à petro 2 points
si le mec a enchaîné les coups tordus
wesh mais je suis
[Musique]
opération des livraisons ce matin alors
si bouffer on est arrivé aux juifs même
pas seulement important non pas des
métiers facile monsieur ouais ça a bien
marché en cuisinant matin jean désinor
de corte est vachement petites emplettes
à tanger 4 regardes et tu veux mais un
grand écart pour mettre à ton niveau
n'est en rien les grands elle est grande
par le coeur ça c'est la boîte me 9 et
se dit très content je vous ai emmené
avec moi dans les coulisses pour voir un
peu comment ça se passait au niveau de
la présentation maintenant on a le
spartak on va l'ouvrir déjà je tiens à
faire un gros bisou à mathieu de la
chaîne rester connectés dans ces métiers
merci bas de rien qui tient la caméra
sur le pouce pour la vidéo lâché le
blues est allé voir la chaîne bélanger
soutient le sud africain mathieu
s'achève restez connecté vous pas les
lois c'est vachement sympa c'est très
cool ça les passionnés je les adore
battus et tsn mines fsu alors on va se
faire un truc très rapide on va s'ouvrir
on va regarder comment il est fait en
ressort une première prise en main
alors vous savez avec moi ou quoi que sa
boîte c'est marrant de dire faut pas que
sa boîte sur une boîte
voilà
on ouvre
design by chez omis on retrouve ici
alors pour la boîte elle est un peu
standard on commence à voir la m'habitue
d'aujourd'hui de ce que fait chier omis
une version globale smartphone calais en
tout cas assez intéressant alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a là
tac ne pas le faire tomber on fait des
effets comme ça à laverty du peuple je
te l'envoie sur ta tête mathieu 5 1 non
non on fait gaffe qu'est-ce qu'on va là
de quoi ouvrir votre tiroir de cartes
sont juste là ça c'est plutôt cool
on a une petite coque à l'adaptateur
alors première chose et pas des mois
messieurs dames
attention spectacle
pas que j'arrache tôt parce que c'est un
smartphone de prépresse et qui repart
donc si je la rage comme un sauvage je
vais me faire engueuler ça quand même
relativement dommage adaptateur usb tilt
c'est avec une prise jack parce que sur
le smartphone vous n'avez pas de prise
jack d'ailleurs vous le savez je passais
mussolini et plaisir disparaîsse de plus
en plus des smartphones et si on n'y
fait pas exception
donc dites moi vous la question est ce
que vous aimeriez que les marques
concert des prix jack ou alors est-ce
qu'au final vous vous en pâte et les
roustes aux ça c'est un truc important
alors on retrouve à l'intérieur une
petite doc on s'en fiche on carte de
garantie on s'en fiche ou petit coq
ils ressentent ces petites coques ont
des cours ensemble
[Musique]
donc c'est pas folichon folichon mais
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal qu'elle
soit dans la boîte et moi comment vous
la trouvez un commentaire intéressant
pas intéressant parce qu'on dirait pas
comme ça j'en sors du gordon en fait on
dirait que le mec il s'en fout
complètement et surtout son bazar et
bien fait pas du tout
[Musique]
pas mal on va se faire dans la poste
derrière en sécurité là on ouvre la
caverne d'ali baba on a bon c'est un
grand classique on a un chargeur de 18
watts dans la recharge rapide usb usb
sais et je crois que c'est à peu près
tout ah non on a une petite structure
côté la spa sont moi je pense que c'est
là où se mettre les écouteurs là c'est
un modèle de presse iapa d'écouteurs
mais vu qu'on a un petit truc là pour
l'ouvrir
je pense que le rhabille écouteurs voilà
la bête 1900 alors on à dire quelques
infos qualcomm snapdragon 712 on est
très clairement dans le milieu de gamme
avec un instinct dragon 7 sans doute je
vous montrais les caméras on a trois
caméras l'ariège dont la fameuse sony mx
5 186 avec le capteur 48 mégapixels
capitte serrures fin je vous montre
c'est vachement intéressant on a un
écran de 5,97 pouces amoled
c'est un écran samsung fhd plus chez omi
a voulu faire un produit qui tient bien
dans la main parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
de retours personnes qui leur disent
vous nous faites toujours des plus
grands écrans nous on veut des trucs qui
tiennent dans la main et là pour le coup
est ce smartphone c'est très bien réussi
on enlève effeuillage à l'avant et
feuillages à l'arrière j'aime beaucoup
le dos comme ça avec ce bleu le problème
de ces dos à vous en douterez mais c'est
pas nouveau c'est surtout les
smartphones qui font des doigts en verre
sans les traces de doigts à côté de ça
vous avez un corning gorilla glass 5 à
l'arrière donc il est protégé
si vous le faites tomber alors protégé
n'allez pas le jeter non plus parce
qu'au bout d'un moment vous étiez quand
même de l'abîmé corning gorilla glass
cinq exactement de la même manière à
l'avant ça c'est plutôt cool petit
bouton de volume
ici sur la tranche bouton pour l'allumer
pour l'éteindre un seul haut parleur
mono qui doit être ici ou ici à mon avis
c'est plus la la ça doit être le micro
vous savez un traitement logiciel qui
est fait justement pour permettre
d'améliorer le son bien qu'on ait un
seul haut parleur mono ici mais ça on en
parlera dans les phases de test dans
quelques temps de l'usbc votre tiroir de
cartes sim pour mettre deux cartes sim à
l'intérieur attention ici pas
d'extension aux cartes microsd de
l'infrarouge pour l'utiliser comme une
petite télécommande un micro pour la
réduction de bruit
le choix a été fait par shinobi là
dessus
un smartphone compact c'est ce qu'ils
veulent et vous l'avez très clairement
avec un smartphone qui léger qui est
compact qu'on peut utiliser à une seule
main ça ses couleurs c'est une première
prise en main je vais pas vous dire ce
que j'en pense sur des semaines parce
que c'est pas vrai ce qui est un des
semaines que j'utilise s'affairent à
peine une heure que je lis avec moi par
contre ça quand on est comme ça c'est un
format qui couvrent naissant les formats
des 5,8 pouces c'est pas pour rien que
j'ai omis dans la présentation nous a
fait un parallèle avec l'iphone 10 aces
alors très clairement peut pas les
comparer sont pas les mêmes smartphones
on n'est pas sur les mêmes techno par
contre en termes de format on y est
quasiment 5 97 pousse ses compacts c'est
bien c'est léger ça c'est plutôt pas mal
on a un écran est ce qu'on le voit bien
monsieur monsieur le cadreur on a un
écran amoled 5,97 poussée du fn des plus
de 1340 par 1080 pixels
et oui messieurs dames avec un ratio 19
points 5/9 et il occupe 90,7 rafraîchir
en léger dans mes notes parce que j'ai
pris des notes
en outre et que je connais pas encore
tous par coeur ils occupent 90e 47% de
la façade
absolument alors il est assez lumineux
j'avais un peu le doute en dix ans la
finale est ce qui va être mis ne pas
trop lumineux je trouve quand même assez
lumineux donc ça c'est parfois qui est
plutôt positif donc ça bien évidemment
on va le tester dans quelques jours dont
vous invite dès maintenant vous abonner
comme ça vous serez vous sur ce joli
smartphone haut niveau d'autonomie alors
pas parler de l'autonomie mais je peux
vous dire en tout cas ce qu'il est
intérieure et une batterie de 3000 70
millions terreur comme je voulais 10 et
la recharge rapide 18
c'est pas la plus rapide du monde mais
j'ai déjà pas mal avec de l'usb c'est ça
gagne évidemment vous dirai tout c'est
sur l'autonomie lors du test qui
arrivera très prochainement
vous avez un triple module photo à
l'arrière le principal que vous avez là
c'est la fameuse caméra de sony cellier
1586 qui ouvre à f en points 64 c'est
une caméra 48 mégapixels en gros qu'est
ce que ça fait et bien vous allez avoir
quatre pixels en nombre notamment pour
la photo de nuit
vous allez prendre une photo en 48
mégapixels ça vous sortir une photo de
12 mégapixels en rose allait prendre 4
pixels
ça vous fera un seuil des micro pixel
captera plus de lumière ça c'est bien
ces pratiques
vous avez un deuxième set et l'objectif
de 8 mégapixels j'ai pas l'ouverture
dessus on verra ça effectivement contre
testera aussi vous avez une troisième
caméra c'est un 13 mégapixels san ultra
grand-angle de 123 degrés est qui ouvre
à f 2.4 à l'avant on a une caméra de 20
mégapixels qui cache un petit peu aussi
dans la petite encoche capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est intégrée
sous l'écran voilà qui franchement assez
rapide dans bien évidemment il ya la
reconnaissance de scène il reconnaît 25
catégories de scènes différentes et en
rouge et le chiffre est exact il
reconnaît 206 scènes différentes fois
très précis pas de 105 pas de sens mais
cette dame est bien 206,5 différentes
aux éclairs de la vidéo à 960 images par
seconde enfin tout ça on le verra aussi
peu contestera très prochainement
est ce un smartphone que vous pouvez
précommander dès aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
si vous intéresse il ya un lien en bas
dans la description pour les
précommandes et oui mais
sur mac darty parce que notre
partenariat avec son lac darty vous le
trouvez en 6 giga de ram + 64 giga de
stockage à 369 euros et pour les
adhérents fnac darty je dis ça je ne
suis pas du tout j'ai pas du deal avec
mac darty mais pour les adhérents vous
avez 20 euros de remise contre c'est
vrai que c'est plutôt intéressant et
aussi un conduit mais si j'ai bien drame
semble s'agir de stockage vous l'avez à
399 euros
donc ça c'est aussi intéressant et vous
avez aussi les 20 euros de remise pour
les adhérents fnac darty qu il faut
savoir vous pourrez retrouver ailleurs
dans plein d'autres bonnes boutiques
courant mai et vous avez l'exclu fnac
darty jusqu'au 1er mai ça me laisse un
petit peu de temps si vous êtes les
premiers à l'acheter vous pouvez trouver
en ligne saas intéressante autre grosse
nouveauté qui a été annoncé par celle
d'aujourd'hui
c'est la trottinette professionnels
qu'ils appellent très exactement c'est
la mi électriques scooters pro en gros
vous avez une plus grande autonomie vous
avez un moteur de 300 watts vous avez
une autonomie de 45 km alors qu'avant
vous aviez 25 à 30 km en autonomie et
vous allez pouvoir aller un peu plus
vite notamment au niveau des pentes des
pouvoirs afin de la vitesse de 25 km/h
sur les pentes à 12 degrés toute façon
j'avais parlé de plus vite que 25 km
heure parce que la législation française
parce que l'art c'est dur à dire parce
que la législation française ne vous y
autorise pas vous avez un petit écran au
niveau du de l'avant pendant laquelle
vitesse vous voulez on voit dans quel
mode vous êtes mode et comme aux sports
et compagnie alors notre porte conclure
c'est pas non plus une ferrari mais à
voir ça on testera aussi très
prochainement vous voyez votre batterie
vous voyez si vous phares sont allumés
août en fin de compte je file à côté de
pencher votre tête et vous le verrez
vous avez un double système de freinage
pas mal de protection protection contre
les courts-circuits entre les sources à
sa fin une trottinette qu'ils aient
évolué qui pèse 14 kg qui est un kilo et
demi plus lourdes que celles d'avant et
que vous trouvez à 499 euros pareil pour
l'instant vous la trouvez sur fnac darty
si vous intéresse vous ai mis un lien en
bas dans la description et je voulais
cette trottinette
on va le tester prochainement le mineur
est ce on va tester prochainement dont
vous invite à faire une chose c'est à
vous abonner comme ça vous serez tous
voilà justement vous ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que vous trouvez intéressant ce
smartphone qu'est ce que vous pensez de
la trottinette vous marquez tout ça en
bas en commentaire et voulu essayer
d'être évidemment très jolie pouces
bleus
merci mathieu salut merci on est à
nouveau les harmoniques
prenez soin de vous et restez connectés
sur la chaîne de messieurs drôle tu veux
ça tellement bien